a few days ago we had this big issue the
server raid that we have that our
footage and a text files or one died
fortunately we have local backups of a
lot of the effects and all the raw
footage so we're able to finish the
video however the making of video which
had been finished a week ahead of time
contract though somehow managed to do
all this amazing work way in advance our
backup wasn't quite up to date and we
lost
fortunately there is such thing as a
data recovery service that you can take
your hard drive suit and get them fixed
and that is happening right now
but with 12 terabytes it kind of takes a
while so one week from today there will
be behind the scenes making up video for
this judge drone I just felt like
sharing it with you guys that's you
haven't forgotten welcome to our